PLAYS, ESPECIALLY AT THAT AGE.
THE FACACIS YEAR THAT HASN'E OF
NET.
DOBSON, THOUGHT HE SET UP THAT
PASS UP THE BOARDS W WILL
TAKE IT INSTEAD.
SECOND-ROUND PICK IN .
HE CAME IN THE LEAGUE -- EXCUSE
ME, F F SAVE.
>> Brendan: STUTZLE TRYING TO
GETHIS PUCK BOUNCES THROUGH FOR
MATT NLY WAY TO STOP HIM IS
SLASHING HIM.
WE'RE SEEING N WRAPPED
AROUND,AIN.
POWER PLAY OVER, GETS
BLOCKED.
IT
AGAIN, PALMIERI.
TAPS IT TO
BEAUVILLIER.
BEAUVILLIER ABLE TO KEEP THAT
PASS IN THE ZONE.
RIPS IT ACROSSDING THE
BOX OUT ONCE AGAIN.
BEAUVILLIER ACROSS THE
BEAUVILLIER CURLS AND LOOKS.
RIGHT SIDE GREENE WITH SOME
ROOM.
THAT SHOT BLOCKED AS IT HIT AND
INTIMIDATING THE OTTAWA SENATORS
DY GRABBING AHOLD
OF HIM.
>> Anson: OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> Brendan: THE PUCKRS
WEARING THE JERSEY TO SET T UP
THE SCORE SHEET, BUT THE
EXPERIENCE THEY'RE PASSING ON TO
NOAH DOBSON I I FOR BROWN.
BROWN WANTING THE BACK DOOR FEED
BROKEN UP BY
>> Brendan: HE CAN TELL I KNOW
NEAR THE END OF THIS PERIOD WHE
DOBSON, A LITTLE HELP FROM, ZACN
SEMYON VARLAMOV, TOP TEN IN BOT
IN.
FORSBERG GOT JUST ENOUGH TO TIP
IT AWAY FROM THE NET.VELOCITY,
FOR GOALTENDERS TO CONTROL THOSE
REBOUNDS.FORSBERG.
HE JUST GOT A PIECE WITH THE
GLOVE. GAUDETTE TO GET HIS
STICK ON THERE.
ANDWS EVERYONE UP HIGH AND
HE BUMPS IT DOWN LOW T DOWN LOW.
>> Brendan: HERE'S
SHORT SIDE, OFF AND
WHO'S DOWN ON HIS KNEES TRYING
TO TAKE COVERS UP THAT PUCK WIT
TKACHUK DRIVING TO THE ISLANDER
CRSENATORS.
IT'S A THREE-GOAL THIRD FOR THE
ISLES.H PARISE THROWING THE
PUCK TO AN EMPTY